et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Boris Vallot bonjour merci d'être là de
président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par votre presse régionale
Boris Vallot c'est sud-ouest bonjour
on va évidemment parler de la réforme
des retraites une journée de
mobilisation et donc prévu jeudi on
imagine que vous allez aller manifester
Boris Vallot est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment pouvoir faire reculer le
gouvernement
des syndicats quand on voit que 80% des
Français ne veulent pas de cette de
cette réforme
et bien on se dit que ce n'est pas les
Français qui ne comprennent pas la
réforme du gouvernement mais le
gouvernement qui comprennent pas qui ne
comprennent pas les français donc
j'espère oui que il y aura de la part du
gouvernement une écoute et un recul
cette réforme Boris Vallaud le
gouvernement explique que c'est pour
sauver le système par répartition est-ce
que vrai ou faux c'est une super
futuriste analyse c'est bien de partir
de ce diagnostic est-ce que il y a péril
en demeure est-ce que le système des
retraites est menacé d'effondrement est
ce que le Conseil d'orientation de la
retraite dans chacun se revendique le
dit le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites traite dit noir sur blanc il
n'y a pas de dérive incontrôlée des
dépenses du client déficit qui se
profile de de la branche de la branche
vieillesse il dit qu'il y aura un
déficit selon différentes hypothèses et
donc il n'y a pas de péril en la en la
demeure par ailleurs si vous regardez la
protection sociale dans son entier et
les hypothèses de chômage par exemple
4,5 % et bien le déficit annoncé sur la
branche vieillesse pour être compost
compensé par l'excédent qui va être de
20 milliards de lunédique ce sont les
mêmes cotisations des Français qui sont
des mêmes poches qui financent l'un et
l'autre il y a bien des moyens de
répondre de répondre à cette question là
et quand vous regardez le détail vous
dites finalement et le Cordy n'y a pas
de de dépenses incontrôlée oui il dit
aussi qu'il y a un problème de recettes
en réalité l'équilibre tient un déficit
de recettes pourquoi parce que il y a
dans les hypothèses du gouvernement le
retrait le recul de la part de la
contribution de l'État ça fait des
recettes en moins il y a aussi une
hypothèse qui est de façon durable le
gel du point d'analyse ou sa très faible
augmentation des fonctionnaires et du
coup une contribution une cotisation des
fonctionnaires qui vont être paupérisés
s'appauvrir vite que les tasses du Vince
il y a dans les hypothèses du
gouvernement un retrait de l'État et
donc un problème de recettes et si on
parle de recettes bah il y a mieux plus
juste que cette proposition de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans qui est en
réalité un impôt sur la vie des gens
un impôt qui est un impôt dégressif en
plus c'est-à-dire que l'effort à faire
par les plus modestes classe populaires
les classes moyennes est supérieur à ce
qui est demandé à ceux qui ont travaillé
tard qui vivront oui mais le
gouvernement n'en fait pas la
démonstration ou de façon cosmétique il
dit par exemple que ce dispositif qui a
été pensé par François Hollande des
carrières langues va être améliorée
c'est pas vrai quand vous commencerez à
17 18 ans ce sera pas 60 ce sera 62 ans
donc il y a toujours j'allais dire ce
prix payé par les classes moyennes et
les classes et les classes populaires et
l'effort a accomplir pour cela va être
beaucoup plus important que pour ceux
qui n'ont pas ces difficultés qui ont eu
des carrières qui n'étaient pas j'allais
dire pénible pour pour le corps pour les
épaules pour le dos qui ne n'était pas
une forme de lessivage parfois
psychologique et physique et c'est vrai
j'allais dire dans chacune des
situations il y aura plus de gens qui à
64 ans mourront avant d'atteindre à
l'âge de départ à la retraite pour les
plus modestes et les catégories les
classes moyennes ce seront aussi eux qui
auront la plus grande probabilité
d'avoir des carrières courtes ou des
carrières très courtes ou d'avoir une
espérance de vie en mauvaise santé la
plus grande donc il y a une grande
injustice dans ce système et il y a
évidemment si on parle d'un déficit on
le prend en considération d'autres
façons de le financer il y a quand même
des mesures il y a des mesures alors on
en a un peu parlé pour les carrières
longues il y a des mesures pour les
carrières hachées il y a la prise en
compte du congé parental il y a une
augmentation des retraites à 85% du SMIC
pour les carrières complètement pour
vous il y a rien à jeter parce que vous
vous défendez en fonction du refus il y
a rien à prendre dans cette réforme
vous prenez bien sûr mais ce n'est pas
divisible si le gouvernement oui mais
c'est divisible
améliorons les petites pensions
améliorant la question de la pénibilité
et nous nous proposons d'aller beaucoup
plus loin mais on renonce à cette impôt
sur la vie des gens sur la vie des
Français les plus modestes vous savez ce
que fait le gouvernement après le quoi
qu'il en coûte il a décidé qu'il allait
en coûter à ceux qu'on a applaudis à 20h
voilà c'est ça la réalité parce que par
ailleurs il a refusé cet effort de qu'on
aurait pu demander à ceux qui le peuvent
au grandes entreprises avec les hypers
profits avec les hyper dividendes avec
les grandes fortunes cela ils seront pas
mis à contribution
ils ont un président tous les autres ils
ont besoin d'être représentés ils le
sont par exemple pour vous il faut
mettre les entreprises à contribution
augmenter les cotisations c'est ce que
dit notamment François Bayrou écoutez on
peut commenter les cotisations il faut y
avoir des surcotisations pour les
revenus on n'est pas obligé justement de
faire contribuer plus ceux qui pour
lesquels les fins de mois sont déjà
difficiles on peut socialiser un certain
nombre de droits qui aujourd'hui sont
des socialistes des droits socialisés
des assujettir à des cotisations
sociales parce que mesurez bien une
chose quand on vous dit tenez on vous
donne un chèque Macron des socialisé
d'abord c'est pas du salaire et puis en
réalité ce que l'on vous donne comme
argent là on vous le reprend une autre
manière au moment de la retraite et
notamment en vous faisant travailler
plus longtemps sur la pénibilité oui il
y a d'autres choses la pénibilité il n'y
a pas de réintroduction des quatre
critères l'exposition produit chimiques
les gestes répétitifs les vibrations
enfin il y a quatre critères qui ne sont
pas rétablis ça va concerner
peut-être des propositions vous évoquez
la question des femmes il y a un certain
nombre de femmes qui vont être gagnantes
je crois que c'est quelques milliers
mais il y en a quelques dizaines de
milliers qui vont être perdants dans
cette réforme et tout cela et documenté
donc
le gouvernement est dans un public
reportage pour une réforme qui est
injuste est-ce que c'est un hasard
est-ce que le gouvernement fait sa vie
qu'il y a des gens qui n'ont pas compris
je ne le crois pas voilà justement sur
l'âge sur l'âge de départ vous êtes
contre les 64 ans mais c'est bien la
gauche Boris Vallaud qui a fait passer
la réforme Touraine qui impose les 43
années pour quelqu'un qui travaille à 20
ans ça veut dire 63 ans pour une
retraite à taux plein donc on est
au-delà de l'âge légal au-delà des 62
ans je crois que vous renoncez à cette
réforme
à un moment donné il faut se poser la
question de savoir si la justice qui
doit la sous-tendre peut être améliorée
ou pas la question des carrières longues
de ceux qui ont commencé tôt de ceux qui
ont eu des métiers pénibles voilà qui
use
entre les 5% Français les plus riches et
5% de français pipeau il y a 13 ans de
différence d'espérance de vie entre un
cadre et un ouvrier c'est 6 ans est-ce
que vous trouvez que ce que c'est juste
la réforme c'est-à-dire tous ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler après 21 ans
devront aller jusqu'à 75 ans
pénible ceux qui ont une carrière
pénible dans le dispositif qui était
imaginé mais qui a été fichu par terre
par le gouvernement il y avait la
possibilité précisément d'une certaine
manière de travailler à égaliser les
temps de via la retraite et les temps de
vie en bonne santé
et là tout ça n'est pas reconnu donc
je crois qu'il faut à toute force
s'opposer à cette réforme elle est
injuste il y a d'autres voix pour
équilibrer le système est-ce qu'il est
parfait il n'est pas parfait les
carrières hachées et en particulier pour
les femmes ne pas être carrière complète
demeure très injuste mais vous savez
aussi que c'est dans la meilleure des
carrières on se construit la meilleure
des retraites voilà pourquoi nous nous
battons sur les salaires sur le partage
de la valeur ajoutée sur l'augmentation
du SMIC parce que quand vous vous vous
avez un salaire vous préparez votre
retraite vous cotisez vous financez la
retraite des actifs mais vous financez
ou vous comptez sur le fait que on
finance la vôtre quand on se bat contre
la réforme de l'assurance chômage c'est
parce que les règles actuelles font que
quand vous êtes au chômage vous allez
moins vous créez de droits à la retraite
qu'avant tout ça est un juste le
gouvernement
une dernière question sur l'âge pour
terminer quel est votre position sur
l'âge parce que chez les socialistes on
entend deux positions il y a ceux qui
disent il faut maintenir la retraite à
62 ans comme c'est le cas actuellement
et ceux qui disent non il faut revenir à
la retraite à 60 ans moi je dis que ceux
qui meurent tôt doivent partir tôt voilà
et donc l'autre
système et aujourd'hui je veux dire
aujourd'hui la seule chose qui est
importante et qui me paraît importante
de dire et pour jeudi c'est ce que nous
disons il y a un fond de refus c'est la
retraite 74 c'est eux qui sont au
gouvernement c'est eux qui veulent
imposer c'est eux qui veulent imposer
pas des abattoir c'est celle-là
que ceux qui partent que ceux qui ont
des vies difficiles parent plutôt
ensuite quel que soit les propositions
de manipès et vous pouvez le dire 60 ans
avec un certain nombre d'années de
cotisations ça veut dire que et bien les
plus fragiles pourront partir plus tôt
juste sur la nups il y a la
manifestation des syndicats mercredi le
19 la nuit pêche organise une marche le
21 le PS ne veut pas y aller c'est
toujours sur cette ligne là est-ce qu'il
y a une fracture une différence de
d'appréciation
il y a une différence qui n'est pas
irrémédiable puisqu'on sera tous dans
les rangs de la mobilisation sociale des
manifestations auxquelles les
organisations syndicales à l'unisson
revient depuis 2010 ont appelé jeudi et
mettre c'est pas dans le mouvement
social c'était ce qui était demandé par
les syndicats et c'est ce que ce que
nous souhaitons est-ce que nous ferons
donc nous serons dans les manifestations
et on fera pas tout seul la CGT énergie
menace d'avoir recours à des coupures
ciblées pour les élus qui s'opposent à
cette qui soutiennent pardon cette
réforme des retraites qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette méthode non mais moi je
suis pour que
en toutes circonstances dans le cadre de
la loi il y a des manifestations elles
sont importantes ensuite moi je ne suis
pas dans une organisation syndicale dans
un parti dans un parti politique il y a
ces manifestations c'est le mouvement
social il y aura des rendez-vous
parlementaires en des circonstances dont
on ne sait pas exactement ce qu'elles
seront avec des procédures que nous
allons étrener d'une certaine manière
dans cette dans cette légalité
je fais le constat que alors que nous
sommes un parlement j'allais dire
qui n'a jamais été aussi plus réaliste
il est pas toujours bien traité on l'a
vu à la fin de l'année 2022 une dizaine
de 49,3 parfois la première ministre sur
base restait pas de débat elle arrivait
on était en train d'entrer dans
l'hémicycle c'était déjà terminé ceux
qui arrivent
sur deux textes sur budget ils sont
obligés de la sécurité sociale le
gouvernement le gouvernement dit que sur
les eaux textes ils ont réussi à trouver
des accords avec les parties y compris
avec vous d'ailleurs
et budget la sécurité sociale au fond
c'est une façon une philosophie
politique une façon de regarder le pays
quand on s'oppose à la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale c'est
parce que nous faisons le constat
constat accablé et accablant que le
budget de la santé
aura été en réalité compte tenu de
l'inflation c'est en valeur réelle
défalquer de l'inflation le plus
défavorable depuis toujours et que là au
gouvernement de vie ça va augmenter et
bien non en fait c'est une baisse de
0,6%. mais quand vous avez vos alliés de
la France insoumise qui disent on va
déposer 1000 amendements par député ça
fait 75000 amendements est-ce que deux
facto vous ne poussez pas le
gouvernement à utiliser le 49-3 d'abord
il y a pas de nouveautés c'est pas
tel ou tel groupe politique a inventé
ces pratiques les socialistes l'ont fait
un certain moment de la vie
parlementaire quand il n'y a pas
d'autres moyens et des amendements
doivent aussi on a vous savez je sais
pas si vous savez exactement comment ça
se passe si ici il y a plus que là je
pense vous savez très bien comment ça se
passe mais on a des moments de de de
d'expression de débat de politique
générale on discute des articles on
verra ce qui se passe nous-mêmes nous
n'avons pas encore arrêté notre
stratégie
par député Boris vallon on est dans la
virgule mais vous savez le 49-3 au fond
où les procédures de démocratie
expéditives que le gouvernement nous
réserve sont des mauvaises manières
faites au Parlement mais vous vous dites
que vous avez pas arrêté votre stratégie
ça veut dire que vous aussi vous
pourriez déposer des centaines
d'amendements par député socialiste
c'est que on réfléchit on s'interdit
rien il y a des procédures
parlementaires on est en train de
regarder vous savez que le groupe
socialiste et coutumier de de de trouver
des interstices qui permettent de mettre
des grains de sable est-ce que demander
un référendum sur cette question je
crois que sur des sujets aussi
importants en essayant de les poser en
terme clair poser la question aux
Français pas forcément une une mauvaise
une mauvaise idée en tout cas
on sent qu'il y a besoin de ce débat
l'autre sujet inquiétude des Français
c'est la question de la hausse des prix
le gouvernement veut mettre en place un
panier anti-inflation en demandant au
distributeur de vendre une vingtaine de
produits de première nécessités
quasiment à prix coûtant est-ce que vous
soutenez cette démarche écoutez tout ce
qui peut améliorer la vie la vie des
Français honnêtement on prend est-ce que
c'est suffisant certes non il y a la
question évidemment de la relation elle
est ancienne historique entre les
producteurs et les distributeurs et la
grande distribution ça continue d'être
posé il faut évidemment continuer
travailler mais plus 4 jours la grande
distribution sur cette demande du
gouvernement
il est possible qu'elle joue le jeu mais
est-ce que elle ne reprendra pas d'une
main ce que elle consentira d'une autre
je ne sais pas mais pardon je reviens au
fond à ce qui est un désaccord de fond
nous nous disons que au fond les
meilleures mesures en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat c'est le plus juste partage de
la richesse qui est créé dans ce pays et
la plus juste partage entre les salaires
les bas et les revenus depuis 2008 les
salaires les 10% de français les plus
mieux payés augmenter trois fois plus
vite
je dis que on peut pas toujours esquiver
quand on parle du travail
de la question des salaires la question
du niveau du SMIC la question en réalité
du pouvoir de vivre des Françaises et
des Français il y a des mesures qui sont
conjonctuaires elles là où ils attendent
au fond de pouvoir vivre de leur travail
pour voir environ dignement que les fins
de mois se soit pas le 15 mais que ce
soit le 30
et là le gouvernement
n'avance pas beaucoup sur le sujet on va
parler du Parti socialiste vous soutenez
Olivier Faure qui affrontera donc
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol jeudi pour
savoir lequel des deux sera élu premier
secrétaire du Parti Olivier Faure qui
jeudi dernier lors du vote sur les
textes d'orientation a fait moins de 50
%, est-ce que c'est un échec pour vous
il a fait quasiment 50% ce qui n'est pas
rien il y a du pluralisme et il y a du
débat dans le parti tant mieux mais une
très grande partie une quasi majorité
des parlementaires ont des
parlementaires pardon des militants
socialistes on souscrit à cette à cette
à cette stratégie et en face de lui il y
a des
gens qui disent nous au fond l'union de
la gauche soit c'est non
soit c'est oui mais c'est nous bon tout
ça est pas très clair là nous on est
dans une stratégie et c'est le tandem
d'Olivier Faure et de Johanna Roland un
parlementaire et un élu local disent en
réalité nous pouvons être pleinement
socialiste dans l'union de la gauche que
nous avons construit au moment des
élections législatives et j'en suis le
témoin privilégié et je le dis le
militant il faut être sans ambiguïté sur
ce sujet là depuis 6 mois à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le travail avec nos
partenaires nous arrivons à la fois à
nous parler à travailler ensemble à
chercher à nous convaincre et nous ne
lâchons rien nous comme socialiste et
être nous-mêmes et à se poser la
question de ce que nous pensons comme
socialiste on n'a pas enfilé de camisole
et je crois que dans ce que nous avons à
construire pour l'avenir face j'allais
dire au libéraux et surtout à l'extrême
droite qui est là qui est menaçante avec
lesquels il faut être intransigeante et
combattre pièces à points en lui coupant
la route des classes populaires et bien
je crois que nous pouvons exister et que
c'est un espace de refondation
français nous ont dit entendez-vous nous
sommes en train de nous entendre est-ce
que nous entendons surtout non est-ce
que nous renonçons j'allais dire quand
on invente des accords chacun affirmait
sa position non et à convaincre jamais
je le fais nous le faisons nous devons à
mon avis continuer dans cette voie et le
coup de frein je crois que il serait de
mauvaise augure de mauvaise augure pour
la suite et puis est-ce que Nicolas
meilleur lui propose un débat lui dit si
je dis dans cette entre deux tours si je
puis dire pourquoi le refuser il y a de
la fébrilité dans le camp d'Olivier fort
honnêtement j'ai pas eu l'occasion de de
parler de cela précisément à Olivier
mais il y a pas de fébrilité de la part
d'Olivier forge je crois qu'il y a de la
détermination moi je veux dire je ne
fais pas reproche à nos militants de se
poser la question de savoir est-ce qu'on
existe est-ce qu'on n'existe pas
j'entends dire l'alliance oui
l'alignement non mais il y a pas
l'alignement on en a fait la
démonstration depuis depuis six mois y
compris parce que dans certaines
circonstances vous n'avez pas voté du
tout la même chose sur les textes et
puis on a réussi quand même à construire
des projets communs des combat ce second
tour est incertain Boris Vallot ou pas
forcément penser que c'est joué moi je
je fais la supposition que quand on
répond aux inquiétudes des militants et
je viens d'en faire pour une et bien on
peut dire lever un certain nombre de
d'hypothèques et se dire et bien faisons
ce pari faisons ce choix stratégique et
puis il nous est dit aussi on a pas
travaillé alors écoutez-moi je tiens à
la disposition de ceux qui n'en auraient
pas eu connaissance c'est tout à fait
possible le projet du Parti socialiste
qui a été présenté à Blois aux
universités d'été je veux dire c'est pas
très épais
une centaine de pages c'est c'est plus
que beaucoup de problèmes
le camp de Nicolas meilleur
Olivier Faure n'a pas travaillé le PS de
produits
a défendu par exemple à la fois la
dotation en capital pour tous les jeunes
le minimum jeunesse c'est nous avec des
avec les collectivités départementales
qui a proposé par exemple
une une des mesures sur la rénovation la
rénovation thermique c'est nous c'est
considéré par les associations comme la
meilleure proposition pour sortir 12
millions de Français de la précarité
énergétique en 12 ans qui a travaillé
sur la recherche
tout le monde de l'autre côté parce
qu'apparemment non
il faut plusieurs il faut qu'on soit
dans l'idée que nos adversaires c'est
pas d'abord nous-mêmes vous pouvez en
sortir où il y aura une réunion possible
les deux camps pourronter des élections
je dis au fond de la clarté aux
militants nous avons travaillé
un PS complètement divisé je crois pas
je crois pas qu'on est le luxe de cela
vous savez moi je j'ai une une
focalisation quand je suis dans la
missile et que je vois sur le banc en
face de moi
une extrême droite prêtait tout qui
prétend défendre les classes populaires
mais qui en est en réalité l'adversaire
résolu je m'inquiète quand je vois la
dureté de la vie des Françaises et les
Français je me dis il faut parler aux
classes populaires et au classement
moyenne pas pour parler Kaël mais comme
conditions pour parler à tous nous
devons parler des services publics non
seulement de leur proximité mais de leur
intelligibilité on fait des politiques
publiques que plus personne ne comprend
vous savez ce que c'est remplir un
formulaire CERFA pour demander une aide
pour un enfant handicapé c'est un
supplice d'écrire en une page de projet
de vie de l'enfant c'est ça la vie
quotidienne vivre de son travail du
travail digne la santé l'accès aux soins
tout ça et bien nous pouvons le défendre
et donc nous avons travaillé non
peut-être pas su le faire savoir le
faire savoir suffisamment il faut
regarder aussi ce que nous avons raté
mais enfin l'avenir est devant nous
François Hollande apporte son soutien à
Nicolas meilleur signal et dit qu'une
victoire de l'évier fort serait fâcheuse
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez
rien
c'est pas bien qui est l'intervienne
dans ce débat
ce qu'il veut comme tout en chacun et
moi je vous ai dit ce que je pensais
Nicolas meilleur Rossignol dit que si il
est élu premier secrétaire et si Adrien
catenin serait intègre la nuque il
demandera au groupe socialiste donc à
vous de voter leur participation à
l'intergonie la raison c'est une débat
qu'on peut avoir et je crois que sur ce
sujet là Olivier Faure a été clair
puisqu'elle dit qu'il pouvait pas
rejoindre nos bancs
donc sur un vote
évidemment des questions que nous nous
poserons que nous nous sommes que nous
nous sommes posés et on verra les
modalités est-ce que la France insoumise
aujourd'hui c'est un problème pour la
nuit parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est un
problème pour la nuque pardon mes
failles je sais pas si vous êtes
totalement obsessionnel mais le problème
c'est les fins de mois difficiles le
point le problème c'est que quand on
arrive pas à se faire soigner à la
campagne qui est il y a des pertes de
chances et qu'on meurt plutôt qu'en
ville ce qui est un problème c'est la
captation de beaucoup de richesse
et bien c'est de tout ce dont on parle
et à chaque fois qu'on a un désaccord
que ce soit avec la France insoumise que
ce soit avec le Parti communiste que ce
soit avec nos nos partenaires
écologistes nous le disons et on le dit
sans réserve vous savez moi j'ai j'ai
pas peur de ce à quoi je crois j'ai pas
peur de ce que défendre les socialistes
je crois que c'est juste et c'est ce qui
donne de la force y compris dans le
travail en faisant ensemble mais enfin
mesurer dans un pays fracturé la
richesse que c'est de que la gauche se
parle que la gauche travaille ensemble
qu'elle assume ses désaccord qu'elle
cherche des convergences que nous nous
fassions partager au fond ce qui est une
culture de la construction d'un
compromis c'est-à-dire accepter de
prendre la société dans sa complexité
dans ses contradictions et puis au fond
cette espèce d'audace qu'il faut avoir
cette épée dans les rangs
soyons audacieux pour les Français qui
parfois n'ont pas le luxe de pouvoir
l'être et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
Maurice merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité la Une de sud-ouest de personne
oui avec Philippe Etchebest ce qui est
en une célèbre chef qui a rencontré nos
lecteurs au journal et c'est à dire ce
matin dans ce qui peut être merci quand
on n'est pas habitant du Sud-Ouest et
voilà on invite à lire merci beaucoup
Maurice vallée on passe au club des
territoire